I'm always very very jittery during the
plane ride I just want up and I want out
they jump from eleven and a half
thousand feet it is the most amazing and
wonderful exhilarating rush that I've
ever felt my life
I was falling towards the ground at 120
miles an hour I was seeing the world
below me and I knew that my life was in
my hands she looks at me I'm nodding
getting her the okay signal she deployed
properly and it's a good Scot
girl my parachute came out and initially
I could look up and it was everything
you skydiver ever wants to see it was
perfect
[Music]
I heard a really loud snap is so
insanely loud
a velcro strap holding one of the two
breaks has come undone every hair on my
body stood on end and it's like time
froze for second like whoa with a
parachute off balance Shamus spins out
of control
it was the most gut-wrenching sickening
feeling of my entire life she pulls a
tab to release the main chute
I thought why waste my time when I have
a Reiser I looked up and I seen the top
my parachute and blue sky and nobody I'm
like where she at she's in freefall just
3,000 feet from the ground god he's in
trouble
Oh God
shaima's life now depends on a reserve
chute i've real slowly just looked up
kind of hold my breath wonder is this
gonna be any better
and no more than I looked at it I knew I
had another problem
the lines come out not in the reserve
chute fails to open fully she came close
enough and I could see not only is she
under reserve she's under failing
reserve I was in a body to earth
position basically I was my whole body
was facedown toward the ground another
tailspin
she's shouting back in it's not working
I'm trying what else do I do and that
still just gets me today to think of
this
[Music]
after I had fought it and had tried
everything they told me to do and I I
kind of went from being mad scared sad
to just simply accepting what was
getting ready to happen
I said okay Lord is my time to come home
just please do not make this hurt
and she hit the pavement I described
except for like an exploding watermelon
just a burst and silence
[Music]